i used to date this incredible looking
woman just beautiful i mean we're still
together but she's letting herself go
it's if they're an ugly woman at the
back going boo
[Laughter]
what sorry
rude
so sorry when i said there's an ugly
woman on the back you went he's talking
to me yeah
yeah
rude
i mean
[Applause]
self-esteem there's nothing i can do
about your self-esteem
that's why they call it self-esteem
what's your name adam
kelly i'm gonna go soft on you like
every man that's ever seen you naked
how old were you when you when you did
when you said i got to do this so you're
drinking you're non-course 18 yeah
i was 17.
wow
i didn't did i ask you when a man
touched you or when you started doing
stand-up
i come out and it's my trademark i tend
to maybe jump around a little bit what
do you really think about it i think
you're making a fool of yourself
i know it's awkward being here with
hitler anne because you sold a lot more
books than he
did but lately his is getting way too
popular again
hitler make yourself mind comfortable
you look nervous are you nervous yeah i
think i left the oven on
wow
face and shaq you are gigantic
that suit is bigger than the one against
harvey weinstein
the excellent spotlight has been
nominated yeah
the uh the catholic church are furious
about the film as it exposes the fact
that five percent of all their priests
have repeatedly molested children and
been allowed to continue to work without
punishment
roman polanski called it the best date
movie ever
jonathan likes to think of himself as an
innovative free thinking tv maverick and
fashion icon whilst the rest of us like
to think of him as bradley walsh but
with longer hair
jonathan stopped drinking alcohol for 10
years although sadly no one told his
haggard old face
yeah you can tell right
yeah i know right
[Music]
that was that was angry woman energy
right there you hear that
she was like i've dated this type before
no accountability
are you in a relationship miss yes
slightly married
well there you go how do you pop the
question
so no wow that's great because if she
says no he can just push her you know
[Applause]
bob newhart made the claim that he was
my closest friend i have never met bob
newman
i'll put it to you another way bob
newhart goes to many gay parties
i'll never get used to that like to me i
always go by the ocean and to me the
ocean is east
but it's actually west all right it's
actually south in l.a if you're looking
at if you're at venice you're looking
south oh andrew oh andrew someday you're
gonna make somebody a happy spouse
it's actually south if you uh look at a
map and see the trajectory of the
longitudinal attitude thank you andrew
themeless
how is it possible that courtney love
looks worse than kurt cobain
[Applause]
when i first met jimmy carr i thought
wow jeff dunham's puppets are getting
amazing
jimmy you look like a butler in a
haunted mansion
oh julia roberts you live next to me at
the beach you know that thanks for all
the visits
anyway uh
i'm living about two blocks from the
broad never shows up come by and say
hello
we're closer than two blocks i have no
lines julia just not
anyway
[Music]
and now uh on to larry the cable guy
this this is exciting i gotta tell you
i've never roasted a fake character
before maybe next year we can roast
spongebob squarepants
you know i've always heard that david
hasselhoff has sold millions in germany
but like a lot of stories out of germany
those numbers are probably inflated if
not a complete hoax
you're in the air core yes i am hours
with your eyes
put a rubber band on your can and you
can take off
you're a big son of a gun all right guys
you ever think of putting a window on
your face and becoming a building
someone's alarm
does that mean i have to wrap up my set
they're like
that was it
we have something big what was the alarm
for i'm curious
i used to have one of those to feed my
grandma but she wasn't a plant she was a
vegetable so you know
[Applause]
[Music]
look at all these beautiful people here
to pay tribute to you the senator rich
little poor linda on the end paul if you
want to order do it now the kitchen's
going to close
sorry about your seat paul why don't you
get a pillow so you can see us
the irishman
was amazing it was amazing um look
it was my face
it was great
long
but amazing um
it wasn't the only epic movie once upon
a time in hollywood nearly three hours
long leonardo dicaprio attended the
premiere and by the end his date was too
old for him
even prince andrew is like come on leo
mate you know
you're nearly 50 son
um and one of the girls explained to me
half why you have seven women you know
one to put it in and the other six to
move you around
phyllis stiller you're a dear friend and
i must tell you god bless you
god has given you the way you look
do not be ashamed of it when you were
born you probably hit the wall
say what it was thank you
get down funky okay get back up here
lily look at me i'm on national tv
i'm so happy to be here i can drop a log
here we go
okay
voila they bleep that one here we go
i just want to say um richard's come a
long way in 18 years
not funny but
true 18 years ago they'd greet him in
small time town tube
let me take that back
okay
18 years ago they greet him in small
towns by tying a yellow ribbon around
the old oak tree
then they try and hang him with it
all i can say though is
this man's a genius
now who else can take all the forms of
comedy slapstick
satire mime and stand up and turn it
into something that'll offend everyone
no
but this man doesn't want any frills on
his show
all he wants is a loose director
a tight script
and a warm place to rehearse
[Applause]